- What's up y'all, I'm back
with the lovely Katie Stevens.
Give it up!
(audience applauding)
You may wonder what we're doing,
with what looks like a
tropical bar for a doll house.
'Cause it might be weird. (chuckles)
Well, here to explain is our next guest.
You've seen him in "Judas
and the Black Messiah,"
"Bad Trip" and "Bird Box."
He's now the host of a new game
show called "Small Fortune."
You can see it Mondays
on NBC, take a look.
(whooshing sound effect plays)
- [Lil Rel] Let's play small fortune.
(audience applauding)
Take your time, good luck.
(bell dings)
You need to land one more!
(buzzer buzzes)
- Oh, it got stuck on my finger, no!
- Its alright, its alright.
- It fell.
(bell dings)
(audience and contestants cheering)
(upbeat lively music plays)
- They just banked $80,000,
which brings their total to $170,000.
- All right everybody,
please welcome the always
delightful Lil Rel Howery.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat music playing)
I loved your entrance.
Say hi to Katie.
- Hey Katie, how you doing?
- I'm doing all right.
- You got lots and everything.
That was a cool entrance.
I'm into it.
- I kind of want to do it again.
I know, I'm just saying,
I feel like it was nice.
The music was nice, I love it.
Well you have a new game show.
So can you explain what
"Small Fortune" is?
- "Small Fortune" is it's amazingly,
as you can see this model right here.
But it's a bunch of games and these small
I don't know what, small
worlds that we created.
We have like 27 games.
We got great contestants
from all over the country.
A lot of them are friends
and coworkers and family.
It's a lot of personality with the show.
It's so much fun.
I got a chance to wear a new
suit every episode almost.
- All right, all right.
- I was happy about that.
But no, this is a really fun, fun game.
I can't wait for you all to play it.
- Okay.
Well, okay, we have a game
from "Small Fortune" here.
So how does this particular one work?
- This one is called a little tipsy.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] Perfect.
- Yeah, so what you're
gonna do is basically
you're gonna grab this tray with one hand,
and put the tray on one of your fingers.
And you're gonna grab each
drink and put it on the tray.
And then once you do that,
you're gonna attempt to
put the tray on the table
with the drinks on the tray.
- [Kelly] Why'd you say attempt?
Why are you already?
Why are you speaking our failure?
- 'Cause I've seen people play the game.
It's not as easy as it looks.
So you just, I know it looks
easy, but it's really not.
And it's like one of 27 games we have.
- Okay, I'm just saying I was a waitress.
So, feeling confident.
- Yeah, but these are really tiny drinks.
- I was too.
- You were a waitress too?
You know what?
I smell your competition.
All right, all right.
The competitive nature.
- Yes.
- Man, I like how intense this is.
Battle of the waitresses.
- Do you feel it?
Do you feel it?
(Lil Rel laughs)
All right, let's do this.
- Who's first?
- Okay, well, before I go, if Katie wins,
her tiny, tiny photo that you see in there
gets mounted on the Blake
Shelton wall of champions
which is horrible.
It's a horrible wall.
But, Lil Rel, so you take it away.
You lead, and you're asking
who wants to go first?
- Yeah, who's first?
- I wanna go first.
Can I go first?
- [Lil Rel] It's your show.
- Okay.
I'm going first.
Okay, so you take this.
The tiny little.
- [Lil Rel] Okay.
- Okay. Okay.
- [Lil Rel] Now you put one drink.
- [Katie] It's just a little tilted.
Oh, she's got it.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Lil Rel] You can't
base it off one drink.
There's one on there so far.
- I am so impressed right now.
- [Lil Rel] Oh wow.
- [Katie] She's making this look easy.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Katie] Wow.
- And then, it goes a
little something like this?
- [Katie] Oh, wow.
- What!
I'm so crazy talented.
(Katie laughs)
- [Kelly] 'Cause you said
not everybody does that.
- [Lil Rel] I don't know about
like how easy you making it look.
'Cause it's not...
- [Kelly] It's just my skills, Lil Rel.
(Lil Rel laughs)
- [Lil Rel] Your turn, Katie.
- [Kelly] All right.
Katie, no pressure, but,
that was awesome.
- I'm shaking.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- All right.
- [Lil Rel] You got this.
- [Kelly] Okay. Your turn.
- All right.
- No pressure.
- [Katie] Am I allowed to maneuver?
or do I have to like do it from here?
My limbs aren't that long.
Okay.
- [Kelly] Okay.
Hopefully you didn't get too close.
Oh, 'cause I'm seeing how
close you're getting on there.
- [Katie] I'm already shaking.
I'm so nervous.
All right.
(quirky anticipatory music playing)
I have a feeling I'm not
dispersing this weight evenly.
- Oh my God. Oh my God.
Don't drop it Katie.
- [Katie] Kelly?
(Lil Rel laughs lightly)
- Ooh, okay.
- [Katie] Can't wait to see
what my concentration face looks like.
Oh!
(Kelly screams)
(horn honking)
(Kelly imitates horn honking)
Let's do tie breaker.
- Yes! We just both win.
- [Katie] So my picture
still goes on the wall?
- I'ma pick somebody 'cause I mean,
for game play that was great.
That's gonna be great TV
the way you just played it.
- Oh, did I do it wrong?
- No, she just did it way better.
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh my God!
- [Lil Rel] She wasn't shaking.
(Kelly laughs loudly)
- I should not be
penalized for nervousness.
Did you see?
I like twisted my body.
I twisted my body around to
give those people their drinks.
- That was amazing.
- [Lil Rey] Great job, ladies.
Great job.
- That was a great job!
We both did great.
- [Katie] That was.
We did great.
- [Kelly] I'm just saying,
we would've been amazing.
So technically, I won.
- [Katie] I disagree.
But here's the thing.
She disagrees.
And here's the thing,
I just really wanna see
this little tiny photo
on the Blake Shelton wall of champions.
(Lil Rel laughs)
So it's going up there people.
I'm saying we tied.
So thank you guys so much.
- I can't wait.
This is awesome.
You can see "Small
Fortune" Mondays on NBC.
You can also see this
on the Blake Shelton wall of champions.